I really thought this was wonderful you
guys know Amala epinobi who's been on
the show many times she's a contributor
at prageru she's a good friend of mine
she's she's become just an absolute
All-Star in fighting this woke nonsense
she went on Dr Phil and uh debated with
a professor from Arizona State his name
is Neil Lester on cultural appropriation
and I just thought this was wonderful a
lot of the time that people that I've
seen are called out for this it's not
that they were making fun or mocking in
some way it was just that they had
adopted
a fashion or a style or whatever I would
say that's a performance so if
somebody's culture and somebody's
identity becomes a performance then it's
reductive so if you're reducing for
example say the Civil Rights Movement to
an afro and you wear that or you wear
dreadlock wigs you know that
Rastafarians May wear you do that
because it's edgy because it's cool but
ultimately because it's not you and
you're getting some kind of cultural
capital from that by doing it and and
who's hurt by that well it's not a
matter of who's hurt by it it's who's
being disrespected by it well who's
being disrespected by the whole culture
of people whose identities are wrapped
in whatever you're dressing into and can
then take off of all you don't agree I
don't no you think worrying about
Appropriations is a waste of time I
think not only is it somewhat a waste of
time but it's nearly impossible you just
mentioned there are nearly hundreds of
ways that one could appropriate somebody
else's culture or their their livelihood
and to to expect any one human being to
keep on top of that throughout their
entire life I think is an unrealistic
ask and I think imitation is a form of
flattery I appreciate my food by eating
it I appreciate the hair that I wear by
wearing it by putting on the clothes
that I that I wear and every single item
around us in this room could probably be
attributed to a certain culture do we
have to constantly worry about what
culture we we gain things from so really
put those on the same level absolutely
racism and sexism they're on the same
level as cultural appropriation that's
exactly so somebody wears their hair
like you're wearing it you put that on
the same level as as racism absolutely I
put that on the same level as white
supremacy because white supremacy is
intersectional a professor I mean this
man is a professor at Arizona State
everything that he said there is
complete nonsense except it's nonsense
that has now been wholly imported into
the Democrat Party there are no
Democrats except maybe for Bill Maher
and a small Cadre of other people who
are willing to fight that nonsense you
can wear whatever haircut you want you
can make whatever jokes you want you can
eat whatever food you want you can put
on whatever clothes you want to put on
these people don't own you they don't
own your mind they don't know whether
you're doing something to honor it or
make fun of it and guess what you're
also allowed to make fun of things we
used to joke about everything we've got
you guys remember Don Rickles remember
Don Rickles who would literally walk out
into an audience and talk about the
[ __ ] and the Jew and the black guy
and the Latino and make fun of
absolutely everybody and then everybody
was like oh we're all part of America
we're all in on the joke as opposed oh
oh well I can't make fun of you over
there because you will you you might
blow yourself up or something it's it's
it's so dangerous what these people are
pushing you really just gave an
absolutely wonderful uh rebuttal to that
guy but the point of the clip really was
to show that everything he said there
that is the stuff that Kamala Harris
believes that is the stuff that the
progressives believe and this this is
why they Pander to everybody because
none of it really makes sense but you
just have to keep people thinking that
if someone wears a haircut of a certain
way or eats a certain food that they're
the bad guy and you're the good guy